l'insee indique que l'inflation qui
avait tendance à baisser et qui avait
baissé d'ailleurs assez fortement depuis
le début de 2010 9 jusqu'à atteindre un
point relativement bas en 2020 et bien
cette inflation a recommencé à augmenter
à la fin de 2020 et en augmente
extrêmement vite
au point que aujourd'hui en juin elle a
atteint son niveau de 2010 l'un est là
on peut craindre effectivement que cette
inflation continue d'augmenter et
puissent atteindre les 2% pourquoi pas
les deux ennemis % fin 2020 ou en 2021
donc ça c'est une dimension du problème
l'inflation galopante non seulement aux
états unis mais aussi chez nous en
europe
pour la france l'insee estime un bien
qu'une 5% sur un an un peu plus que le
mois précédent à l'heure où la forte
reprise post pandémie créer des pénuries
sur certaines matières premières allons
nous connaître une hausse généralisée
des prix le phénomène est-il passagers
ou peut-il s'inscrire dans la durée on
voit ça tout de suite avec est
l'économiste jacques sapir c'est notre
rubrique l'édito
[Musique]
ce n'est pas en un an au mois de juin
jacques évidemment alors jacques quand
on parle évidemment de l'inflation
c'est-à-dire de au sein des prix de quoi
parle-t-on exactement
oui bonjour stéphanie alors oui
effectivement on est aujourd'hui
confronté à une hausse des prix qui est
de l'ordre de 1,4 1,5 pour cent en tant
que tel ce n'est pas énorme mais ça
reste néanmoins significatifs et alors
surtout le problème que l'on se pose
c'est de savoir est ce que cette hausse
des prix qui semble lier effectivement à
des déséquilibres entre l'offre et la
demande
au fait que la demande est redémarré
plus vite que l'offre notamment et bien
est ce que ces déséquilibres vont être
passager auquel cas il n'y a pas de
raison de s'inquiéter
ou bien vont-ils devenir plus
structurelle et là effectivement cela
demanderait un ajustement de la
politique économique
injac pour commencer que des limes c'est
sur l'évolution de l'inflation
alors c'est un peu intéressants l'insee
indique que l'inflation qui avait
tendance à baisser et qui avait baissé
d'ailleurs assez fortement depuis le
début de 2010 9 jusqu'à atteindre un
point relativement bas en 2020 et bien
cette inflation a recommencé à augmenter
à la fin de 2020 et elle augmente
extrêmement vite
au point que aujourd'hui en juin elle a
atteint son niveau de 2010 l'un est
alors on peut craindre effectivement que
cette inflation continue d'augmenter et
puissent atteindre les 2% pourquoi pas
les deux ennemis % fin 2020 ou en 2021
donc ça c'est une dimension du problème
alors quelles sont les raisons jeanne de
cette hausse alors une des premières
raisons c'est l'envolée des prix des
matières premières il faut savoir que
l'ensemble des matières premières
aujourd'hui par à la hausse alors que ce
soit l'énergie
on voit bien le prix du pétrole a
nettement augmenté aujourd'hui le
pétrole se négocie autour de 74 75
dollars le baril mais il ya aussi les
produits alimentaires à ce qu'on appelle
les matières premières agricoles
et là c'est plus qu'une eau est pris il
ya des phénomènes de pénurie qui
existent et qui pose aujourd'hui des
vrais problèmes pour l'approvisionnement
dans toute une série de pays ça risque
d'ailleurs de provoquer des émeutes de
la faim
et puis il ya les métaux industriels
tous ces produits en fait sont inclus
dans les produits manufacturés que nous
consommons évidemment les matières
premières agricoles servent à faire nos
animaux et puis les métaux sont dans les
produits manufacturés comme les
automobiles les lakers d'électroménager
quant à l'énergie bien voilà tout le
monde quand il passe à la pompe dans la
semaine peut vérifier que le prix de
l'essence a nettement augmenté depuis
ces dernières semaines et il a question
évidemment qu'on se pose c'est don vient
cette hausse des matières premières
plan il ya trois raisons
fondamentalement il ya trois raisons la
première raison c'est que la demande a
augmenté beaucoup plus vite que l'offre
1 a pu repartir alors la demande elle a
augmenté évidemment en chine mais aussi
aux états unis donc ça c'est un premier
problème la deux le deuxième problème
c'est la hausse des prix du commerce
maritime
ce qu'on appelle par exemple l' indice
baltic dry qui mesurent la tension si
vous voulez sur le commerce maritime
vient cet indice baltic dry
il est reparti à la hausse depuis le
grosso modo juin 2020 et aujourd'hui il
est à son niveau le plus haut depuis
donc ça c'est un point qui va évidemment
dans le sens d'un accroissement du prix
de toutes les matières premières qu'il
faut bien transporter la troisième
raison est bien c'est la désorganisation
des chaînes logistiques qui n'ont pas
encore récupéré de la crise de l'aco
vide etc désorganisation que l'on avait
pensé d'abord être de très courte durée
les on voit qu'elle va durer
jusque fin 2020 voix 2021 est-ce qu'on
n'assiste pas aussi à une hausse des
produits manufacturés et jacques oui
tout à fait et pour les mêmes raisons en
réalité sur les produits manufacturés
on voit que là aussi la hausse de la
demande elle est plus rapide que le
redémarrage de l'offre bien sûr l'offre
va finir par redémarrer un mais pour
l'instant il ya un déséquilibre offre
demande qui est évident il y à aussi
justement ce problème du transport
cette hausse des coûts de transport et
puis il ya évidemment cette
désorganisation des chaînes logistiques
donc tout cela fait qu'il y a
aujourd'hui des tendances haussières à
la fois sur les matières premières et
sur les produits manufacturés
on peut penser et je crois que c'est
assez raisonnable de le penser que en
cela va se terminer que vers la fin 2022
les choses vont revenir à la normale
néanmoins ça veut dire qu'il y aura un
pic d'inflation il y aura un coût
d'inflation de la fin de 2020
au début disons à la fin du premier
semestre 2021 jacques pour l'instant
vous n'avez pas évoquer des faits que
vous n'avez évoqué que des phénomènes de
l'économie réelle est ce à dire que les
injections monnaie non pas stimuler
l'inflation
vous avez tout à fait raison de poser
cette question
stéphanie parce que oui c'est un c'est
un vrai problème alors on le sait les
banques centrales ont injecté beaucoup
d'argent dans les économies alors que ce
soit aux états unis la réserve fédérale
que ce soit en europe la banque centrale
européenne pour justement de soutenir
l'activité
au moment de la crise de la copie dos au
moment de la période et confinement le
problème c'est que une partie de cet
argent n'a pas été bien distribués si
vous voulez il ya des catégories
sociales de la population qui n'ont pas
du tout vu je dirais la couleur de cet
argent d'autres qui ont d'une certaine
manière vu la majorité de cet argent
arriver sur leur compte et concrètement
ça se traduit par deux phénomènes
le premier phénomène c'est
la hausse des cours boursiers si vous
voulez c'est cet argent va s'investir
sur les marchés financiers évidemment on
sait bien que c'est pas l'ensemble de la
population qui joue sur les marchés
financiers c'est une très petite couche
qui joue sur les marchés financers donc
ça c'est déjà un premier effet de
l'injection d'eau d epuis le deuxième
effet et qui est extrêmement important
c'est la hausse des prix de l'immobilier
est ce que l'on constate c'est que cette
hausse des prix de l'immobilier
elle est aujourd'hui général dans
l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
vous savez y être des pays où cette
hausse elle a atteint 18% sur un an
bon la france est plutôt en retard de ce
côté là mais avec 9 % quand même donc ça
veut dire que ce que l'on appelle les
actifs patrimoniaux au sommet dont les
actions les obligations mais surtout les
actions et les biens immobiliers sont en
train de flamber
et ça ça pose un problème pour le budget
des ménages parce que aujourd'hui
imaginer un ménage qui doit changer
d'appartement parce qu'il a des enfants
un nouvel enfant vient d'arriver dans le
foyer ou tout simplement parce que le
travail impose le changement si vous
voulez d'appartement ou de maison et
bien à ce moment-là ce ménage va être
amené à surpayer l'acquisition d'une
maison ou d'un appartement est donc
évidemment ça va peser lourdement sur le
budget des ménages
en conclusion à jacques on aurait donc
non pas une inflation mais plusieurs
oui tout à fait on est en réalité
confronté à deux inflation qui sont
distinctes et la véritable question
c'est de savoir est ce qu'elle ne
pourrait pas se combiner en un seul
mouvement inflationnistes on a d'un côté
l'inflation qui vient je dirais de
facteurs réels
donc c'est le déséquilibre entre la
demande et le redémarrage de la
production leur démarrage de l'offre bon
mais ça on voit bien que ça ne va pas
durer éternellement
c'est une question qui sera réglé un
pire à la fin 2022
bon il ya le problème aussi
coût de transport de la désorganisation
mais tous ces problèmes sont normalement
appelées à se régler d'ici un an à 18
mois
et puis il ya un autre problème c'est le
problème justement des conséquence de
l'injection de monnaie dans les
économies qui fait flamber les actifs
patrimoniaux qui fait flamber les prix
du logement au point d'ailleurs que la
banque centrale européenne réfléchit à
intégrer les prix du logement dans son
indice des prix et ça ça pose évidemment
un problème très important pour le volet
pour le budget des ménages
alors la question que l'on doit se poser
c'est est-ce que c'est 2 d'inflation
resteront séparés et à ce moment là il y
aura pas de véritable problème puisque
on voit bien que l'inflation réelle qui
pour l'instant la plus forte à qui est
celle qui pour l'instant portes d'une
certaine manière
l'indicé des prix on voit bien qu'elle
va s'essouffler fin enfin disons début
2022 voire fin 2022 ou bien est-ce que
cette inflation va se combiner avec
l'inflation monétaire qui pour l'instant
ne touche que les actifs patrimoniaux et
dans ce cas là elle pourrait
effectivement s'inscrire dans la durée
à suivre donc dans les mois qui viennent
jacques mercier est là